let's begin with a dramatic turn of
events in elon musk's bid to buy twitter
the wall street journal reports twitter
could finalize a deal to sell itself to
the world's richest man as soon as this
week bloomberg news reports it could
happen today the two sides reportedly
met on sunday last week must disclose he
had lined up 46.5 billion dollars in
financing to buy twitter musca said the
company needs to be quote transformed in
order to build trust with users twitter
is scheduled to report its first quarter
earnings on thursday it did not comment
on any potential deals with musk he's
convinced the world that electric cars
should be a thing he's convinced the
world that commercial travel the space
should be a thing now elon musk has set
his site on twitter and i think it will
be very interesting to see if he takes
over the company well it will change the
way you use it because he really wants
to have longer tweets yeah he wants to
have longer tweets he says
public square a public square where
anything goes uh now what i'm worried
about i'm worried about anything where
anything goes right and a lot of people
are a lot of people are i've always said
look i don't know people outside of the
media dc bubble that are on twitter my
family no one in my family is on twitter
except maybe my little sister i don't
think she's like an active user i do
think it's interesting for questions
around journalism uh chris lick who used
to be yeah here at cpcc
this is what he tweeted uh just a couple
of days ago he's going to be taking over
as the head of cnn may 2nd will be my
first official day as the head of cnn my
last day on twitter twitter can be a
great journalistic tool but it can also
skew what's really important in the
world i want to also throw up a comment
that was uh made by dean mckay the
outgoing editor of the new york times
when talking about twitter again saying
this in a memo that was obtained by
various news outlets we can rely too
much on twitter as a reporting or
feedback tool which is especially
harmful to our journalism when our fees
become echo changing i know see vlad you
point out not a lot of people are using
it but it gets picked up right and then
it's reported in other places yeah so
you may not be on it but you certainly
hear about it for sure that's sure and i
know people are going to look at this
and they're going to say well oh if
journalists are worried about it well we
should dig into twitter even more so
there are a lot of fascinating uh facets
to this and we'll see if yeah i like
chris becomes the owner of about it
whole world is watching